"
FAUCIFAWNING.
IT RAYMOND ARROYO REVEALS ALL IN
SEEN AND UNSEEN BUT FIRST, OBAMA
TO THE RESCUE.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
NOW, WHY NOW?
WHY DID BARACK OBAMA DECIDE TO
COME OUT TO PUBLICLY INJECT
HIMSELF INTO THE DOJ FLYNN SAGA?
>> THERE’S NO PRECEDENT THAT
ANYBODY CAN FIND SOMEONE WHO’S
BEEN CHARGED WITH PERJURY
GETTING OFF SCOT-FREE.
THAT’S THE KIND OF STUFF WHERE
YOU BEGIN TO GET WORRIED THAT
OUR BASIC UNDERSTANDING OF RULE
OF LAW IS AT RISK.
>> Laura: IN THE END, WILL THE
FBI’S ENTRAPMENT OF DRUMS FORM A
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR THE
BEST KNOWN AS OBAMAGATE?
WELL, I TELL YOU, MANY QUESTIONS
THAN IN ANSWERING.
WHY DID OBAMA KNOW ABOUT FLYNN’S
CALLED BEFORE THE ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL EVEN KNEW ABOUT
IT?
WHY DIDN’T HE TELL THE INCOMING
PRESIDENT ABOUT THOSE SPECIFIC
CONCERNS?
WHY DID SUSAN RICE WRITE THAT
MEMO TO THE FILE.
WE NOTED AT THE TIME, THIS WEIRD
MEMO WRITTEN AT NOON ON
INAUGURATION DAY.
THE LAST POSSIBLE SECOND SAYING
THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA WANTED
EVERYTHING DONE VIS-A-VIS FLYNN
BY THE BOOK.
WHERE GOING TO ADDRESS THESE
QUESTIONS IN DEPTH IN A FEW
MOMENTS.
SURE, OBAMA WANTED TO GET OUT IN
FRONT OF THE OBVIOUS CONCLUSIONS
THAT HE WAS GREEN LIGHTING ALL
OF THIS ANTI-TRUMP EFFORT FROM
DAY ONE.
BUT I ALSO SUSPECT ANOTHER
MOTIVATION IS AT PLAY AS WELL.
ONE WORD, LEGACY.
DOES HE WANT TO BE REMEMBERED
FOR HOPE AND CHANGE?
OR SURVEILLANCE AND SET UPS?
FOR THE PAST THREE YEARS, AFTER
HIS PARTY’S STINGING LOSS IN
2016, BARACK OBAMA AVOIDED
PRETTY MUCH TANGLING WITH THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THE ONLY TIME, IN FACT, HE
SEEMED LIKE THE OLD OBAMA, WAS
IN 2018 WHEN HE HIT THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL, EVEN FOR LOSING CANDIDATE
CANDIDATE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF GOOD
REASONS.
IT GOT THE OCEAN, YOU’VE GOT
REALLY GOOD CUBAN SANDWICHES,
BUT THE REAL REASON I CAME DOWN
TO MIAMI, BECAUSE THIS TUESDAY
MIGHT BE THE MOST IMPORTANT
ELECTION OF OUR LIFETIMES.
POLITICIANS WILL ALWAYS SAY
THAT, BUT THIS TIME IT’S
ACTUALLY TRUE.
>> Laura: OF COURSE, WITH ALL
THE SAME SWAGGER, HE’S GOING TO
PARROT THAT LINE AGAIN WHEN HE’S
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL FOR
JOE BIDEN.
BECAUSE IT’S NOT JUST THE
PRESIDENCY ON THE LINE, IT’S
OBAMA’S ENTIRE LEGACY.
WHEN A BRASH POLITICAL NOVICE
LIKE TRUMP BE THE DEMOCRATS IN
2016, IT WAS JUST A REPUDIATION
OF HILLARY CLINTON.
IT ALSO WAS A REJECTION OF WHAT
OBAMA HAD ACCOMPLISHED AS WELL.
IN CASE YOU’VE FORGOTTEN, AFTER
EIGHT YEARS OF OBAMA, RACE
RELATIONS WEREN’T BETTER, THEY
WERE WORSE.
AFTER EIGHT YEARS OF OBAMA, THE
RIGHT TRACK, WRONG TRACK NUMBERS
WERE ALSO BAD.
WAGES WERE ALSO FLAT.
THE TRANS-PACIFIC PARTNERSHIP
WAS SO LAME THAT EVEN
HILLARY CLINTON WOULDN’T RUN ON
IT.
THE PARIS CLIMATE ACCORDS?
THEY WERE NEVER RATIFIED, SO THE
OBAMA PROGRESSIVE UTOPIA
COLLAPSED.
NO WONDER TRUMP WON!
FOR THE HISTORY BOOKS, HE NEEDS
TO TURN THAT PERCEPTION AROUND.
HE NEEDS TO SHOW THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT THEY MADE A MISTAKE
IN TRUMP, WHICH MAY HAVE
COMPELLED THEM OF COURSE, THEM
BEING THE FBI, ET CETERA, TO
ENTRAP FLYNN IN JANUARY.
WE ARE GOING TO FIND OUT SOON, I
HOPE, ALL THOSE DETAILS.
DUE TO THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC,
PRESIDENT OBAMA NOW SEES THE
NOVEMBER ELECTION IS WINNABLE.
HE DOESN’T WANT TO BE LEFT BEING
CRITICIZED AS LETTING THIS ONE
SLIP THROUGH THE DEMOCRATS’
FINGERS.
BUT OF COURSE THERE’S ONE LITTLE
PROBLEM HERE.
OBAMA ISN’T ON THE TICKET AND I
DON’T THINK IS GOING TO LEAVE
THAT HIGHLIFE AT NETFLIX TO
BECOME JOE’S SECRETARY OF STATE,
DO YOU?
THIS JUST ALL REMINDS ME OF --
IT’S KIND OF LIKE HOLLYWOOD
TRYING TO SELL A MOVIE SEQUEL,
BUT THE LEAD ACTOR FROM THE
ORIGINAL ONLY ENDS UP MAKING A
BRIEF CAMEO IN THE NEW ONE.
IN THIS CASE, OBAMA AT THE BIDEN
INAUGURATION.
THE DEMOCRATS AND THEIR MEDIA
POODLES WILL FLAIL AWAY AT
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR A PANDEMIC
THAT CHINA STARTED, WE’VE SEEN
THAT.
BUT MEANWHILE, THEIR PRESUMPTIVE
NOMINEE IS ACTUALLY INCAPABLE OF
STANDING UP AND TAKING QUESTIONS
FROM PRETTY MUCH ANYONE.
EVEN A COMEDIAN.
>> I’VE BEEN DOING A LOT OF
LIVE STREAM THINGS AND I’M
GETTING USED TO IT.
IT AMAZES ME THAT EVERYBODY IS,
YOU KNOW, TUNING IN TO SO MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS TO FIND OUT
WHAT’S GOING ON.
>> Laura: WELL, THEY HAVE A
CANDIDATE WHO CAN’T CAMPAIGN.
THE LIKELY VP CANDIDATE, I DON’T
THINK THAT’S GOING TO HELP THEM
MUCH EITHER.
>> ONE NATION UNDER A GROOVE.
[LAUGHS]
AND REPUBLICANS, WHO HAVE
BEEN -- EXCUSE ME, REAL
DEFENDERS OF THE PRESIDENT.
>> DID YOU EVER SMOKE?
>> I HAVE.
AND I DID INHALE.
>> Laura: I LOVE THE FORCED
LAUGHTER.
HOW DO YOU WIN AND ELECTION WHEN
YOUR TICKET -- IT’S SO LAME!
ARE TO BELIEVE THAT BIDEN --
WATCHING EVERYTHING THAT’S
HAPPENED JUST OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS, THAT BIDEN WOULD BETTER
HANDLE THE PANDEMIC THAN TRUMP?
PLEASE!
HE CAN’T EVEN HANDLE AN
INTERVIEW WITH "THE VIEW."
>> THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE --
AS OF 10 MINUTES BEFORE I GOT ON
THIS CALL -- EXCUSE ME, THIS
CALL, THE PROGRAM.
LOOKS LIKE THEY’RE PRETTY CLOSE
TO A DEAL.
>> Laura: SORRY, I CAN EVEN
BELIEVE THAT SOMEONE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
WOULD BIDEN HAVE WORKED BETTER
WITH OUR ALLIES, I DON’T KNOW,
TO STAND UP TO CHINA FOR ITS
LYING ABOUT THE VIRUS?
MAYBE THEY’LL ARGUE THAT.
THAT’S ABSURD ON ITS FACE.
>> CHINA’S GOING TO EAT OUR
LUNCH?
COME ON, MAN, THEY’RE NOT BAD
FOLKS, FOLKS.
BUT GUESS WHAT?
THEY ARE NOT THE COMPETITION FOR
US.
>> Laura: WHICH BRINGS US BACK
TO WHY OBAMA HAS EMERGED FROM
HIS IMPORTANT WORK AT NETFLIX TO
INJECT HIMSELF BACK INTO
POLITICS.
HE’S A SMART GUY, HE OBVIOUSLY
SEES THE POINT THAT I JUST LAID
OUT.
HE KNOWS BIDEN IS SHAKY AND THAT
HE CAN’T POSSIBLY MATCH THE
GRASSROOTS ENERGY OF TRUMP ON
THE TRAIL, OBAMA KNOWS THIS.
THUS, A BACK TO THE FUTURE
STRATEGY FOR DEMOCRATS TO BE
THEIR BEST BET.
ULTIMATELY THOUGH, THE SHOWS --
JUST THINK ABOUT IT FOR MOMENT.
IT SHOWS A COMPLETE INTELLECTUAL
BANKRUPTCY ON THEIR PART.
THEY CAN’T POINT TO A SINGLE
EXAMPLE AS TO WHETHER POLICIES
WOULD DO BETTER THAN TRUMP’S
EITHER BEFORE OR AFTER THE
CORONAVIRUS HIT OUR SHORES.
AND THEY CAN’T REALLY PUT BIDEN
OUT THERE FOR AN EXTENDED PERIOD
OF TIME WITHOUT AMERICA SEEING
HIS OBVIOUS FRAILTY.
FOR MOST CANDIDATES, BEING
LOCKED IN THE BASEMENT, THAT
WOULD BE A BAD THING.
BUT FOR BIDEN?
IT’S A GIFT.
THAT LEAVES OBAMA TO DO THE
HEAVY LIFTING.
WHO NEEDS BIDEN OBVIOUSLY TO WIN
FOR HIS OWN LEGACY AS MUCH AS